مشاهد الفوضى في مدينة
كمان الإيرانية، انفجار أدى إلى حالة من
الفوضى عندما دوى انفجار ثان
الآلاف تجمعوا لإحياء
ذكرى وفاة
القائد العسكري كوم سواني الذي قتل في
غارة جوية أمريكية في بغداد قبل أربع سنوات
انفجاران مزدوجان على بعد أقل من ميل من قبر
سان، مما أسفر عن مقتل أكثر من 100 شخص
وإصابة
العديد من المسؤولين الإيرانيين.  يُنظر إلى
هذا الهجوم العام على أنصاره على
أنه ضربة للنظام الإيراني
الذي لديه العديد من الأعداء
داخل وخارج
البلاد [الموسيقى]
في لبنان، وقد أحيا زعيم إيران بحسب
وفاة سومان ولكنه استخدم أيضًا
خطابه يوم الأربعاء لإدانة
مقتل يوم الثلاثاء  مسؤول كبير في حماس
على
أراضيه، استهدفت الغارة في جنوب بيروت
صلاح الري والعديد من الأشخاص الآخرين
فيما وصفته حماس بأنه
اغتيال جبان، وبينما قال مسؤول أمريكي لشبكة
CNN إن إسرائيل كانت وراء
الضربة، كان المسؤولون الإسرائيليون حريصين حتى الآن على
عدم القيام بذلك.  تحملوا
المسؤولية علناً لم تتحمل إسرائيل
المسؤولية عن هذا الهجوم، لكن
أياً كان من فعل ذلك، يجب أن يكون واضحاً أن
هذا لم يكن هجوماً على
الدولة اللبنانية، ولم يكن هجوماً حتى
على الحسا، وربما لم يكن الهدف في
عيون إسرائيل، بل المدعومين من إيران.
ولطالما حذرت الجماعة من أن أي هجوم على
الأراضي اللبنانية من شأنه أن يؤدي إلى رد فعل
بنفس القدر من الخطورة على
الأراضي الإسرائيلية منذ بداية الحرب
بين إسرائيل وحماس. وقد تم احتواء القتال
بين إسرائيل وحزب الله
إلى حد كبير في
منطقة الحدود الجنوبية للبنان، إلا أن ضربة برازين في
بيروت  أثارت الأحداث في قلب منطقة الحسا
مخاوف بين الولايات المتحدة
وحلفائها من إمكانية اندلاع حرب واسعة النطاق
بين إسرائيل
وأقوى قوة شبه عسكرية في الشرق الأوسط
أو حتى على نطاق أوسع في جميع أنحاء
المنطقة.